ne soyez pas et annie si je ne vous ai
pas encore présenté de sujets féminins
mais chez la femme les des formations
linguistiques se manifestait jusqu'à
présent par l'écriture et les lettres de
femmes sont loin de temps était pour
nous des documents est irremplaçable
on l'adjoint monsieur serge gainsbourg
vous parlera en spécialiste d'une
maladie dont l'étude ne cesse de le
passionner
en relisant ta lettre je m'aperçois de
l'orthographe et toi ça fait deux ce
toit que j'aime de poing cannes aime par
dessus tout
le meut 10 points il en manque un
que tu t'en fous
je t'en supplie points sur les i
fais-moi confiance
je suis le score va sans accent grave
des apparences ce ridicule c majuscule
c'est aussi bien tout ça m'affecte ça
c'est correct au plus haut point
ce tu renonces comme ça cependant à
m'écouter avec la vie comme ça s'écrit
j'en finirai pour me garder ne prend
qu'un des temps devant qu'une
taupin de coeur il n'y a pas d'erreur la
rn gens mourir n est pas français
le comprend du port
soc quand tu affrontes ça sera la faute
là il y en a pas moi je te signale que
garder on ne prend pas de
mais n'en prend qu'un cachet au moins
n'en prend pas de haut
cette can aura différents
tout retombe à l'eau le cafard les
pleurs les peines de coeur aux oeufs
dans l'eau
mais aujourd'hui la queue